hey all this is Jeremy Jones again and I
just saw ya Legion I don't know about
you but I've heard people say this movie
is offensive or blasphemous like if you
see it somehow means you've had coupling
with the beast yeah now it's not
offensive it's poor construction shitty
execution and generic characters and
poor construction yeah I don't care if
I've already said that that's what makes
Legion horrible now I really wanted to
like this movie or at least have fun
with it a death squad of angels closing
in on mankind making his last stand
fighting shoulder to shoulder with a
rogue angel should have been at the very
least entertaining so the premise goes
God is pissed off and is set to
eradicate mankind and instead of doing
something foolproof like say a supernova
yeah I know God but I'm pretty sure that
would do the trick
God has set in motion a long drawn-out
process using angels to wipe us out
because if he executed an efficient plan
we wouldn't have the worst two hours
I've seen on screen this year and I know
this year is only three weeks in but I'm
pretty sure this movie will take that
title for a good couple weeks now one
angel who's gone rogue helps a group of
who-cares fortifying maan pause diner to
wait out the apocalypse specifically to
keep alive one woman's unborn child and
then they're met with a couple of waves
of people possessed by angels who are
trying to kill them angels that for the
most part act like zombies meets the
girl from the ring who ultimately led by
an angel played by that one guy who
plays a douche in everything and the
characters offer nothing to this movie
there's a generic hodgepodge of
characters that you would find in a
movie like this they throw in a couple
of deeper meaning of life monologues
that you think are gonna be cool but
they ultimately serve just to draw out
the runtime of this movie now the big
plot holes to just have you scratching
your head in the movie ultimately happen
in the last 30 minutes or so which I
can't go into without spoiling the movie
for you but yeah the plot holes are
there by the end of this movie you're
left with 101 questions and then I
realized that trying to pull logic
reason or structure from the construct
of this movie is like trying to pull
logic from the plot of Pirates no not
that pirates that pirates yeah
ultimately this movie was like a bad
version of the prophecy mixed with a bad
version of the mist mixed with a really
bad version of terminator so like I said
I really wanted to like this movie as an
action movie but a bad script horrible
pacing forgettable characters and subpar
acting just makes you forget about the
movie by the
time you get home from the theater yes
officially when I walked out of this
movie my one thought was that I would
have rather watched slow agonising
career suicide performed by the rock so
do yourself a favor and skip this [ __ ]
and if you like what you've seen here
click on the link in the sidebar see
more videos and subscribe or just click
here